URL building is a helpful feature
in Flask to create URLs based on
the functions they execute.
This is really helpful when you want
to create links to other pages inside
your application.
To build a URL to a specific function,
we can use this url_for() method.
This is one of the many helper functions
that Flask makes available to us.
The documentation for
url_for() can be found on
the Flask documentation page here.
I want you to open up
the menu.html template and
add some new hyperlinks to edit and
delete each menu item.
Remember that this URL for helper method
returns a complete URL stream, so
place it where it belongs
inside of an anchor tag.
If your code works you should have edit
and delete links now on every menu item.
Read through the documentation for
reference.
Consult your fellow students
if you have any questions.